he's the columnist for the LA Times and
certainly a lot to write about recently
bill plashy joining us
the most recent column at two critical
moments analytics failed the Dodgers now
they face an o2 world series deficit
bill good morning thanks for joining us
how deep is that hole that the Dodgers
are in tonight well they got about nine
innings to get out of it but I mean I
think the one thing that Dodger fans can
take solace in is that we haven't even
seen their best team on the field we had
four there's two again you know and
that's and that's or or couldn't say it
takes sauce is driving him crazy but the
analytics and all the the matchups and
everything at least tonight against the
right-hander for the Red Sox they'll
have their their top three home run
hitters in the lineup for the first time
they'll also have their best starting
pitcher on the mound vanilla in the last
two months Walker Buehler so I think
that's where their hope comes in I think
that the I think if they get one out of
here and then the Red Sox will start
right-handers another right-hander
probably on Saturday so they figure they
got two shots at it so I think you know
I think the holes deeper I think it can
be dug out of I'm also looking at the
analytics and I know the front office of
the Dodgers they love their analytics
and I just can't imagine like in in a
previous decade or generation bill you
know world enough to know that you would
not have sat your left-hander against a
left-hander if you used one of your top
homerun guys and here you got Belanger
Muncie sitting I understand joc Pederson
but Muncie and Bellinger or certainly
Bellinger I just have to have my good
players get some swings there they can't
get one at-bat in the game I I don't
understand the logic can you help me
there yeah yeah it works
no no I really can't help you there must
and it worked it worked in the regular
season it worked brilliantly and it's a
regular season thing and it works over
the course of time and then it worked in
the playoffs against the Branson Brewers
because they have well they did do a lot
of bull penning and they don't have any
really strong starting pitching but if
you have a strong starting pitcher it's
gonna go four or five innings or at
least five innings it really doesn't
seem to work it just I think at some
point you got to step back and say wait
a minute they have on the bench for
World Series Game one a 35 home run
hitter and the NLCS MVP
both of them are on the bench for the
first three games or yes at some point
so I've got sit back and say what are we
doing here
and somebody you gotta let the players
play and I think this has always been
the criticism of the analytics heavy
front offices and again it's got they
know they've won six divisions straight
division championships out here this is
a second straight World Series so it
works to a point but at some point I
would think that you and helmets kind of
take over and I think Dodger fans are
going crazy about that saying okay just
play the best damn plane
yeah yeah that that's what I came away
with I even talked to Johnny Bench about
that yesterday I like can you imagine
you would be sitting somebody because
the analytics say the lefty on lefty is
not in our favor at some point like Kirk
Gibson never would have made it to the
plate bill because the analytics would
have said well he's broken down he'll
never be able to hit Denis Eckert like
all these things you know what Bucky
Dent have gone to the plate on a righty
righty matchup here or you know Aaron
Boone I could just there at some point
you have to have a gut feeling it feels
like more than just these are the
numbers well what's one of the biggest
pressure hits you can have the biggest
pressure appearances moments in all
sports would be to hit a home run in a
game seven
Cody Bellinger did that and I know what
the numbers say but I just think you'd I
just figuring Cody Bellinger maximized
he could have run into one or two the
last couple of nights
couldn't they I mean that's my point and
again I'm not you know I'm not saying it
doesn't work it didn't work over the
course the regular season because it
does and it doesn't work in certain
matchups but in its shorts in a
seven-game series with good starting
pitching it just it just doesn't make
any sense
so yeah so it's a shame it's weird we're
saying well the Dodgers have a chance
now because they're gonna play their
best players oh wow we're talking to
Bill Pulaski LA Times and around the
horn joining us Dan Patrick show four
days ago
I was seeing headlines that you know
it's a time for the Lakers to panic
question mark and now that they want a
couple of games in a row and they beat
the Nuggets who are gonna be at one of
the top teams in the West so now what is
the spin here I saw last night Dana I
saw the future it's a 4-2 don't panic
it's a four seed I could see it now I
was ready to say LeBron what really last
week I'm like this team when LeBron
don't play the same old stinky Lakers
they're horrible
but no he's he seems to have had an
impact they they they they they shared
the ball last night bunch of guys in
double figures they played defense they
hustled Kobe Bryant was there selling
this book so he was on the side on the
sidelines there and and it was it was a
huge night and I think no and I think
that showed what it can be and again
again this time adding more than a four
or five seed but I think they can get
there they did a pretty good nuggets
team and they did it was a team effort
they did it without Rondo and Ingram out
there so even even Lonzo ball felt last
night
Alonzo ball I thought has no place the
early returns seemed to me like he has
really no place on this team even he
seemed to fit in last night so I think
maybe the bonds having the LeBron effect
is starting to work and it could be big
or see that's I can smell it from last
night
but you said Lonsdale ball fit in last
night but when Rondo comes back and
Ingram comes back it just feels like he
gets pushed down the totem pole here and
and I just know I know I know we have to
see more of that you're right no you're
right you got to see more of that but
does he seem to be like the extra piece
that in my opinion last week I'm
thinking they're gonna trade this guy
before before February because he just
doesn't fit in here but if LeBron can
make it happen if he can get these guys
involved if we can figure out a way to
get it spacing on the floor with him and
again last night showed what they could
be and you know they came back early and
they played defense so again I just
think I think the the ceiling is is back
to where it should be which is again of
four or five C lon Joe's dad we haven't
heard much from him I was wondering if
there's and it's wonderful oh my god no
problem yeah I know but I don't know
this isn't a coincidence is it it feels
like there was some ball that was set in
the offseason like magic said to you
know lawns lonzo's dad you know here's
the deal you know what let's let's just
be quiet let's put your son's future
let's just be quiet no now I think that
happened last year has been worse I
think they even threatened betrayed him
I had even threatened to trade the kid
if the Dead didn't shut up and I think
that worked I think what work with
LeBron James I think finally Lavar ball
is Lavar ball or that's his name right
labarie Alomar ball he's okay
he almost almost forgotten who he is he
saw a guy who's actually bigger and more
status than he is
he didn't
Johnson had this current status among
you know among the sporting public to
stand him down but the Bron does and I
think LeBrons presents finally shut up
levar he realized and Andy got scared he
said well maybe the Lakers don't have
the guts to trade my son
LeBron oh sure trade my son so I'm gonna
keep my mouth shut so I think LeBrons
presences had wide-ranging effects and
one of them mr. shut up levar if there
was a fan vote on four more Dodger wins
the Rams going to the Super Bowl or the
Lakers go to the NBA Finals that's a
good question however as we've seen
during this postseason the Dodger
attention has been enormous out here and
people I think after 30 years I think
even casual Dodger fans are going crazy
about the Dodgers the Dodgers I think
David anybody would take the poll would
be a one hundred ninety and nine percent
get the four more wins break that
30-year drought
I think the Rams are still kind of a new
thing here and I think LeBron is kind of
a thing in progress but I think fans
judging from the metrics of our
newspaper and what people reading and
what people responding to the Dodgers
are overwhelmingly people are just so
sick of the thirty-years and the Dodgers
are sick of hearing it I think the
Dodgers that that's still the number one
thing by far how crazy is traffic going
to be on Sunday in Los Angeles bill
it'll be like the Tuesday or Wednesday
be every day out here I mean it's just
that's just the way you're just the way
it is I mean I think yeah and I mean
also everybody's talking about all the
differences for events the only event
the only two events that are gonna get
the big stuff or the Coliseum their
hands to cot Rams Packers and the
Dodgers you know Red Sox the the folks
downtown are used to have the way they
have their back ways to get it and all
that stuff so it's a different everybody
out it's bad yeah I'm going to get it in
the car right now we're down to do it
around the horn studio it's going to be
terrible it's terrible every day so good
to visit with you Bill have a great
weekend thanks for spending some time
thanks for having me yeah that's bill
Plante ski LA Times and around the horn
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]